[Music]
you guys like those get Doug Dutch
they're not digesting whoa it's not too
late for call let's see shall we go
youngest to oldest how we do it oh
here's the present for Nathan from
grandma grandpa nickels go Nathan open
it up it's all you bud oh wow
we'll race cars
[Music]
apparently it's a rave on wheels yeah
let me see it Thalia my Velvia it is a
time for a present for you daddy this is
for the baby yeah I thought you might
like it it's it's a bit big it's like a
twelvemonth but the baby's first car
hearts so I can't even looking out fish
it so you give you a little break okay
[Music]
we're turning this off that's gonna get
old real quick yeah all right Nathan
there's more presents in here Nathan
there's more present in here look yeah
look it dad
[Music]
Nathan there's more presents more
presents
it's a bird Tommy and I need these
presents it's for paw Patrol isn't it Oh
[Music]
Oh buddy quickly and we're gonna wear
boots okay look at this look at this
behemoth actually you know yes
that's a fire truck isn't that that's
witty the Pooh yeah chase is your
favorite paw patrol isn't it a pair of
winter boots here's a present for mommy
[Music]
it's hard to find one that's long enough
but skinny enough for you so you know
it's that's what you have is when you
have a tall supermodel wider it's for Oh
[Music]
Nathan Nathan your present okay go Oh
what is that
Oh many trains little mini Thomas the
train's now I love guessing presents I
know this one is in bubble wrap
it's light is square I'm guessing it's
some sort of men's jewelry like a tie
tech but that's I'm only like 40 percent
sure on this one so earphones
noise-canceling earphones thank you
thank you
it's good cereal oh thank you I like
this thank you very much Shelley okay so
once again I love guessing presents this
one it shifts slightly it's an
open-ended box and it's fairly heavy I'm
fairly certain this is a book but it's
quite heavy so I think it might be two
books shrink-wrapped together and if I
had to guess knowing my wife I guess
they're photo albums okay and I would
say they're probably photo albums either
from facebook pages or from childhood
photos so what Becca has done is this is
a company that takes your facebook pages
and turns him into photo albums so she's
taken my cats and car Facebook page
which I've had for since 2014 and she's
turning into a photo album song our
little fishing adventures and posts and
everything are are up on there that's
pretty cool Becca thank you very much
first Christmas present from my boy
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm gonna put it up here high where I
can see it and Nathan is less likely to
destroy it there we go there's the Tommy
tree ornament Merry Christmas everybody
come here Tommy we got one more thing
got more thing you know what happens
there might be some presents in your
stockings by the chimney so should we go
check the fireplace into the fireplace
it's wait is that where you put the
cookies last night and they're all gone
maybe come here this is yours you gotta
open up your soul is that like for
writing no it's our drawing oh my
mistake
Thank You Tommy you telling the truth
yes cuz you're wearing a camera oh my
goodness look at this carnage look at
that
[Music]